Du fängst an, Dinge anders zu sehen. So wie sie sind.
Ist das wie eine Gehirnwäsche? Sieht man danach die Welt ganz anders?
Da wird es mir schon ganz anders, wenn ich das höre.
Wenn du realisierst, dass wir alle Eins sind,
warum solltest du einen andern schlagen wollen?
Vielleicht, weil er Geld hat und du nicht.
'Mein Mann gehört mir.'
Siehst du das auch so? -Nein, das seh ich nicht mehr so.-
Ich wäre lieber Eremitin, also so was zu machen.
Auf diesem Hof leben Menschen ohne persönlichen Besitz.
Für mich klingt das krass. Kann das funktionieren?
Als Erstes
wird mein Portemonnaie inspiziert.
Da hat es natürlich
ganz viele Karten.
Ein Kartenmeer.
- Für alle Fälle vorbereitet.
Wenn du dir diesen Stapel so
ansiehst: Was bedeutet das für dich?
Das ist meine Freiheit.
Deine Freiheit?
- Das ist leider meine Freiheit.
Ja, sonst ... Es würde mir
grosse Existenzängste bereiten,
wenn ich das alles nicht mehr hätte.
- Mhm.
Ist das falsch?
- "Ist das falsch?"
Weisst du ...
- Das kennen wir alle auch.
Das ist nichts Neues.
- Ja.
Aber ihr seid hier,
um einen Schritt weiterzukommen.
Ja.- Ihr findet,
es sei falsch, dass jeder ...
... seine Freiheit hier finden muss.
- Wir haben ja Geld.
Warum habt ihr kein eigenes?
Weil es nicht notwendig ist.
Ich finde es so viel einfacher.
Woher kommt der Gedanke:
"Ich möchte das für mich."?
Was will ich wirklich?
Habe ich einfach Angst,
es nicht zu haben?
Was macht mich als Mensch aus?
Doch nicht das Portemonnaie.
Ihr alle arbeitet auf diesem Hof,
wirtschaftet in eine Kasse
und jeder kann rausnehmen,
was er oder sie braucht?- Ja.
Also, wir schauen uns gemeinsam an,
wer was und wie braucht.
Theoretisch
kann jeder selber was rausnehmen.
Aber wir leben so,
dass wir zusammen schauen wollen,
wie wir das machen.
Es ist so entspannt. Man muss sich
um nichts Sorgen machen.
Man macht es zusammen.
Bei mir passiert gerade viel.
Ich habe eine gewisse Abwehrreaktion.
Ja, ja.
- Weisst du, wenn ich ...
Es klingt ja super, aber für mich -
das denke ich -
wird es spannend, herauszufinden,
warum ich als Erstes denke:
"Oh, okay."
Ich erfahre, dass es
die Yamagishi-Gruppe seit 1994 gibt.
Anfangs waren es bis zu 50 Leute.
Heute sind es noch zwölf.
Agnes war von Anfang an dabei.
Das ist dein Zimmer.
- Danke vielmals.
Wie ist das: Hat jeder ein Zimmer
oder eine ganze Wohnung?
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Früher, als wir so viele waren,
hatten wir alle ein Zimmer.
Nur ein Zimmer? Wirklich?
- Und Gemeinschaftsräume.
Eine grosse Stube usw.
hatten wir schon.
Aber zum Schlafen war
die ganze Family in einem Zimmer.
Ging das?
- Ja.
Ich schaue etwas komisch.
Da hast du ja gar keine Privatsphäre.
Nie.
- Das stimmt.
Aber wir
konnten uns auch zurückziehen.
Es gab schon Rückzugsräume.
Es ist nicht so,
dass wir nur aufeinandersassen.
Es ist ein Balanceakt:
Wo ist es mir noch wohl?
Ich merke einfach,
dass wir zusammen weiterkommen.
Wirklich?
Allein bleibe ich oft stecken
und ich komme nicht weiter.
Und dann kommen Inputs von aussen.
Dann öffnet sich der Blick wieder.
Es wird farbiger.- Ja.
Das Leben?
- Mit jeder Person, ja.
Super.
Dann richte ich mich etwas ein.
Gleich hier draussen hat es ein WC,
das du benutzen kannst.
Da oben ist ein Container
für die Dusche und noch ein WC.
Super.
Ihr hattet also früher auch nur
Gemeinschaftsbäder und -duschen.
Wie auf dem Campingplatz.
- Ja, genau.
Okay.
- Ohne 50 Rp. zu bezahlen.
Ja, genau.
Dazu müsste ich z.B. sagen:
Ich teile gerne, aber nicht mein WC
und nicht meine Dusche.
Mhm.
Das wäre ...
- Das verstehe ich gut.
Das verstehe ich so gut.
- Bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Gewöhnt man sich daran?
Nein.
Es gibt Momente, in denen
man sich etwas sammeln muss.
Und dann ist es wieder okay.
- Ja.
Ja.
Ich schätze deine Ehrlichkeit sehr.
"Nein."
Danke vielmals. Bis später, Agnes.
- Gerne.
Die Idee des Zusammenlebens
stammt ursprünglich aus Japan.
Ein Bauer namens Yamagishi
gründete sie.
Sie leben vom Verkauf von eigenem
Brot, Fleisch, Gemüse und Eiern.
Es gibt keine Hierarchien.
Jeder soll mithelfen
wo und wie er will.
Christoph z.B. war früher
dauergestresster Kunstrestaurator.
Ich habe realisiert, dass ich Dinge
nicht richtig geniessen konnte.
Vorher?
Z.B. jetzt beim Grasverfüttern.
Ich wäre zufrieden gewesen,
wenn es fertig wäre.
Während der Arbeit ...
- ... hatte ich keine Zufriedenheit.
Wirklich?
Jetzt kann ich alles machen
und es ist einfach eine Freude.
Ich mache
von morgens bis abends etwas
und muss manchmal darauf achten,
dass ich das Essen nicht vergesse.
Alles Geld fliesst in eine Kasse
und daraus kann sich jeder bedienen.
Ich überlege,
was ich mir selber wert bin.
Ja.
- Und ... äh ...
Brauche ich es wirklich?
Es ... äh ...
Es betrifft ja alle hier,
wenn ich ein neues Handy kaufe.
Brauche ich das wirklich?
Wenn ich merke,
dass ich es brauche,
gibt es keinen Grund,
es nicht zu kaufen.
Nichts besitzen, aber alles brauchen
dürfen - so lautet die Devise.
Hattest du nie das Gefühl, dass du
für dich selber mehr Dinge brauchst?
Du hast hier ja nichts für dich.
Also, ich fühle das nicht so.
- Ja.
Überlegst du dir das gar nicht?
- Das ist meine Küche.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl ...
... dass das für alle
und das für mich ist.
Das fühle ich nicht.
- Ja.
Es gehört also nicht niemandem,
sondern eher allen.- Ja.
Es ist einfach da
und wir dürfen es brauchen.
Irgendwie so. Das ist mein Gefühl.
- Ja.
Um bei Yamagishi dabei zu sein,
muss man einen Kurs besucht haben -
den Tokkoh.
Dort sei man eine Woche lang
rund um die Uhr zusammen.
Wie habt ihr überhaupt
zu Yamagishi gefunden?
Vor 30, 40 Jahren
waren die Genossenschaften ja gross.
Es gab eine Genossenschaftsbeiz,
eine Genossenschaftsdruckerei usw.
Wir hatten dort zusammen
eine Velowerkstatt.
Dort lernte ich Yamagishi kennen.
Ich sah, dass da etwas anders lief.
Es war nicht einfach nur
der Genossenschaftsgedanke,
und wenn es
ums Fleisch am Knochen geht,
schaut trotzdem
jeder für sich selber.
Dich hat gereizt,
wirklich alles miteinander zu teilen.
Ja. Die Initialzündung findet
wirklich im Tokkoh-Kurs statt.
Man fängt an, die Dinge anders ...
Man hat die Möglichkeit,
den Dingen auf den Grund zu gehen.
Man versucht, zu sehen,
wie es wirklich ist.
Ist der Kurs
ein bisschen eine Gehirnwäsche?
Es kommt mir ein bisschen so vor:
"Man sieht die Welt ganz anders."
Da wird es mir ganz anders,
wenn ich das nur höre.
Da finde ich: Ich möchte meine Welt
nicht anders sehen.
Ist es Gehirnwäsche?
- Also, im positiven Sinn, ja.
Ist das so?
- Es ist eine tolle Sache.
Es löst ... Es ist dieses ...
... Loslassen.
Du kannst
all deine Gedanken betrachten,
du lässt alles hochkommen
und nimmst alles wahr.
Du empfängst es und überprüfst,
ob es wirklich so ist.
Wenn du z.B. jemanden siehst,
spürst du eine Nähe oder Sympathie -
oder eben nicht.
Aber man bleibt nicht dabei stehen,
sondern wird sich bewusst,
dass ich dieses Gefühl produziere.
Das hat nichts
mit dem anderen zu tun.
Mhm.
Und hat das, was ich produziere,
etwas mit der Wirklichkeit zu tun?
Es geht also nicht darum,
zu einer Religion oder
einem spirituellen Führer zu finden.
Oder auch?
- Nein.- Gar nicht.
Eher, dass man bei sich schaut.
Der spirituelle Führer
in dir selber.
Was hast du gesagt,
als er zu dir kam und sagte:
"Du, ich habe da etwas gelesen."?
Ich war schon eher
immer etwas kritisch.
Sicher?
- Ja.
Ich hatte
schon auch den Sektengedanken.
Er ging dann in den Kurs,
kam nach Hause
und dann
passierte etwas Interessantes.
Ich ging erst ein Jahr später.
Aber er
stritt sich einfach nicht mehr.
Er stritt sich nicht mehr?
- Er stritt sich nicht mehr.
Ich war die Einzige.
Aber vorher
stritt er sich auch ab und zu?
Ja, ja, wir hatten jeweils grosse
Diskussionen über alles Mögliche.
Warum hat er damit aufgehört?
Man sieht eine andere Lösung.
Man merkt,
dass es ohne streiten geht.
Man kann ruhig bleiben, zuhören ...
... und dann reagieren.
Mhm.
Nicht einfach
aus dem Affekt raus ...
... Nein sagen.
Ich streite eben gerne.
Ehrlich. Auch in einer Beziehung.
Ich finde es schön,
wenn ich mit jemandem streiten kann,
aber weiss,
dass wir uns trotzdem mögen.
Ich sehe das nicht als ...
Wir haben nicht
keine Meinungsverschiedenheiten.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Ein Streit ist verbunden
mit schlechten Gefühlen oder so.
Ihre Arbeit sei nur die Oberfläche.
Wesentlich sei der Prozess im Innern.
Abends
besprechen sie diesen zusammen.
Vielleicht kurz dazu,
was uns aufgefallen ist
oder wie es uns ging.
Habt ihr heute etwas entdeckt?
Ich möchte von dir wissen,
wie du das erlebt hast.
Was geht bei dir vor -
von heute früh bis jetzt?
Also, es brachte mich wirklich
zum Nachdenken ...
... wie viel Widerstand
ich heute Morgen verspürte,
als ich mein Portemonnaie
abgeben musste.
Ich hätte nie gesagt,
dass mir Geld wichtig ist.
Aber der Moment,
in dem es offensichtlich wurde,
weil ich auch selber sagte,
dass das Freiheit sei ...
Ich habe mich selber entlarvt.
Das war sehr spannend.
Ist das jetzt weg?
- Nein.
* Lachen *
Ich hatte gehofft,
wir dürfen es behalten.
Ich glaube, es wäre passend,
das hier miteinander zu lesen.
"Passage zur Märchenwelt"
von Yamagishi.
"In einem freundschaftlichen,
fröhlichen Dorf,
wo Geld nicht nötig ist, ist Nah-
rung, Kleidung und Wohnung gratis."
"Es gibt keine Entschädigung."
"Es gibt weder Verordnungen,
die zur Arbeit zwingen,
die an die Zeit binden,
noch gibt es Aufseher."
"Man schläft,
wenn man schlafen möchte,
und steht auf,
wenn man aufstehen möchte."
"Es ist ein Dorf, das dem echten,
menschlichen Leben entspricht."
"Falls es Leute gibt,
die so ein Leben führen möchten,
denke ich,
sollten sie es ernsthaft versuchen."
"Falls es Leute gibt,
die so ein Leben führen möchten,
denke ich,
sollten sie es ernsthaft versuchen."
Ich denke ... Ja ...
Wir sind seit rund 30 Jahren daran,
das wirklich ernsthaft zu versuchen.
Miteinander zu arbeiten
ist viel einfacher.
Aber die Leute
wollen das einfach nicht.
Sie strampeln lieber allein und
jeder hofft, Millionär zu werden.
Selbst Bettler hoffen,
noch Millionär zu werden.
Das ist interessant.
Das erstaunt mich immer.
Macht ihr das jeden Abend?
Nicht ganz, aber oft.
Manchmal
bleiben wir bei der Arbeit hängen.
Man kann nicht mehr aufhören,
weil man sich
gerade so über die Arbeit freut.
Er steht extra früh auf.
Damit er
mehr Zeit für die Arbeit hat.
Bei mir ist es umgekehrt.
Arbeitest du am Abend länger?
Ich arbeite möglichst wenig.
* Lachen *
Das zu sagen, ist in der Schweiz
ja fast eine Todsünde.
Ja, es ging lange,
bis ich das sagen durfte.
Schon, oder?
Es ist schlimm,
nicht gerne zu arbeiten.
Das sollte man ja nicht zugeben.
Lieber wie ein Verrückter
bis zur Pension krampfen
und dann in kürzester Zeit
nach der Pension k.o. gehen.
Es gibt eine kurze Nacht:
Um 5.30 Uhr geht es wieder los.
Die Wagen für die Tour
werden gepackt.
Viermal pro Woche verkaufen sie ihre
Produkte im ganzen Kanton Zürich.
Wie ist es gemütsmässig
heute Morgen?
Mit welcher Haltung gehen wir heute
auf die Tour?
Mein Thema ist gerade ...
Manchmal kaufen Leute bei mir ein,
die ich nicht so sympathisch finde.
Ich versuche dann zu denken,
dass sie mir so nahe wie ein Bruder
oder eine Mutter sind.
Das verändert megaviel.
Ich liebe meinen Bruder
und meine Schwester einfach.
Egal, was sie machen
oder was ich fühle,
wenn sie Mist bauen oder so.
Das ist egal.
- Ja.
Wenn ich das
auf alle Menschen übertragen kann,
verändert das viel.
* Telefon *
Yamagishi-Produkte, Cotting.
Hier ist Frau Rickli, guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Ich habe vergessen zu sagen,
dass ich diese Woche Ferien habe.
Ja.
Ist das gut?
- Ja, tipptopp.
Gut, danke.
- Vielen Dank. Schöne Ferien.
Danke.
- Wiederhören.
Siehst du, es gibt Leute ...
Wer war das?
- Das ist eine Nutzerin ...
... die jede Woche bei uns einkauft.
Sie hat vergessen zu sagen,
dass sie heute nicht da ist.
Ah! So süss.
- Ja, sie rufen uns an.
Auf dieser Tour war Herr Stöckli.
Er wurde 94 Jahre alt.
Irgendwann rief uns sein Sohn an.
Sein Vater
habe auf dem Sterbebett gesagt,
er müsse Herrn Cotting anrufen, um
zu sagen, dass er nicht mehr da sei.
Nein.
- Ja, ja.
Das war ein herrlicher Typ.
Sali, Vreni. Ich bin im Anmarsch.
- Ja, hoi.
Ah, super. Danke.
- Ich bin jetzt im Anflug.
Danke.
- Tschau, bis gleich.
Wir haben uns schon Sorgen gemacht,
dass etwas passiert sei.
Wirklich?
- Ja, ja.
Er ist immer so pünktlich.
Habt ihr Kirschen? Wow.
Ja, die ersten Kirschen.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Merci.
Das Geschäft läuft gut.
Sie könnten
noch viel mehr Umsatz machen.
Das wäre einfach möglich.
Man könnte zehn oder 15 Autos
fahren lassen.
Und es würde funktionieren.
- Zu 100 %.
Warum macht ihr das nicht?
- Wieso?
Weil wir keine Leute haben.
Und mit Angestellten
wollen wir das nicht machen.
Wir wollen uns
nicht mehr beschäftigen,
nur damit der Umsatz steigt.
Das ist nicht in unserem Sinn.
Es war nie das Ziel,
ein Geschäft aufzubauen.
Das Ziel war, ein Ort zu sein,
an den die Leute kommen
und an dem sie wachsen können.
Vor Kurzem
sei bei ihnen eingebrochen worden.
Es wurde Geld gestohlen.
Besitz ist euch ja nicht wichtig.
Ihr sagt ja, dass das
eher vom Wesentlichen ablenkt.
Aber wenn etwas gestohlen wird ...
Habt ihr euch darüber aufgeregt?
- Aufgeregt?
Nein, ich glaube nicht,
dass sich jemand aufgeregt hat.
Nicht?
- Ja ...
Es war eine Verunsicherung da:
"Oh, es ist jemand im Haus ...
... der eigentlich
nicht dorthin gehört."
Jemand, der sich
einfach Zutritt verschafft hat.
Wir reden darüber,
wie man das Geld braucht.
Wäre er zu uns gekommen und
hätte gesagt, dass er Geld brauche,
hätte man
miteinander besprechen können,
ob es möglich und sinnvoll ist,
ihm etwas zu geben.
Aha.
- Ja, wieso nicht?
Es ist ja nur Papier,
das man weiterverwenden kann.
Unterstützung haben sie sich
z.B. für den Bauernhof geholt.
Magdalena ist Landwirtin
und Tätschmeisterin hier.
Sie arbeitet für Yamagishi,
lebt aber selber nicht in der Gruppe.
Was für Vorurteile oder Befürchtungen
hattest du?
Ich habe mich vorgängig
kaum informiert.
Ich möchte ...
... die Dinge
ziemlich vorbehaltlos antreten.
Sie überrannten mich total ...
... als ich mich
beim Vorstellungsgespräch hinsetzte
und eine riesige Gruppe Menschen
dort war.
Da haute es mich fast rückwärts um.
Es sind einfache Leute.
Man kann gut mit ihnen sprechen.
Als ich vom Vorstellungsgespräch
kam, dachte ich:
"Ich komme sicher nie hierher."
Dann überlegte ich es mir aber.
Ich sprach noch mal mit ihnen
und sagte, ich käme als Landwirtin.
Aber
mit der Vereinigung Yamagishi ...
... wollte ich nichts zu tun haben.
Das haben sie akzeptiert.
Es passt.
Findest du es komisch, dass man
alles Geld in einen Topf wirft?
Ich bin nicht materiell orientiert.
Das würde mich im Prinzip
nicht unbedingt stören.
Es würde mich stören, dass ich fra-
gen müsste, wenn ich etwas brauche.
Das ist der Punkt.
Um den Kern von Yamagishi
besser zu verstehen,
habe sie freiwillig
den Tokkoh-Kurs gemacht.
Wie hast du das erlebt?
Das nimmt mich wunder.
Mit diesen Leuten zusammen zu sein
war für mich Stress pur.
Stress pur. Tag und Nacht
zusammen sein - das mag ich nicht.
Ich bin gerne allein.
Aber die Informationen und Gespräche
waren durchaus interessant.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Man hat auch einiges gelernt.
Aber bei einigen Dingen
musste ich Nein sagen.
Was hast du für dich mitgenommen?
- Für mich mitgenommen ...
Ich bin ein direkter Mensch.
Wenn mir etwas nicht passt,
sage ich das auch so.
Vielleicht könnte ich es anders for-
mulieren oder anders damit umgehen.
Sie sagen ja,
dass die Arbeit Nebensache sei,
das Zusammensein sei die Hauptsache.
- Genau.
Zusammen arbeiten ist okay für mich,
aber nicht die Gemeinschaft.- Ja.
Ich wäre lieber Eremitin,
als so was zu machen.
Am Feierabend will ich Feierabend.
Ich will nicht
dieselben Gesichter sehen,
die ich den ganzen Tag
um mich herum habe.
Ich brauche einen Ort,
an dem ich ich bin.- Ja.
Nach 13 Std. Arbeit
wäre eigentlich Feierabend.
Aber die Esel Otto und Louis
haben andere Pläne.
Ja, sie sind abgehauen.
Jetzt sind sie dort oben.
Vielleicht auch schon im Wald.
- Wo gehen die denn hin?
Auf einen Waldspaziergang.
Es gilt, die Ausreisser
in den Stall zurückzulotsen -
ganz nach Yamagishi-Art:
mit viel Ruhe und Gelassenheit.
Die beiden Ausbrecher.
Oh, là, là.
Eine Belohnung für die Esel.
- Eine Belohnung?
Ja, ja.- Du belohnst sie dafür,
dass sie ausgebrochen sind?
Du bist eine gute Seele.
- Sie sind zurückgekommen.
Also, darf ich?
Das haben sie verdient.
Hm? Belohnung.
Das ist die Nachspeise.
Das Leben hier
basiert auf Freiwilligkeit.
Aber was passiert mit den Aufgaben,
die niemand machen will,
wenn jeder nur macht,
worauf er Lust hat?
Kannst du den auswaschen?
- Ja.
Das warst immer du. Hm?
Manchmal putzt jemand anderes.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich ...
Wenn man nur das macht,
was man gerne macht,
und einem das WC egal ist,
muss man nie mehr WC putzen.
Ja, gut,
das kann ich nicht so beurteilen.
Ich habe es gerne so.
Jemand anderes
macht es halt nicht so.
Ob ich damit leben kann ...
Das ist die Frage.
- Das ist interessant.
Wenn du jemanden heiratest, der
eine andere Ordnung hat als du ...
Aber ich habe den Vorteil,
dass ich den im Idealfall liebe.
Dann verzeihe ich ihm viel
oder mache es für ihn.
Aber hier lebst du nicht nur
mit denen, die du heiraten würdest.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Aber die Frage kommt irgendwann,
was für eine Beziehung man hat.
Ja.
Ich habe auch schon gesagt, dass ich
mit fünf Männern verheiratet bin.
In Sachen Putzen oder auch sonst?
- Nein, auch sonst.
Aha.
Wenn ich Schwierigkeiten habe,
versuche ich,
das auch mal so zu betrachten.
Ja.
Früher gab es ja die Kommunen,
die wirklich alles teilten -
auch Frauen und Männer.
Ist das bei euch auch ein Thema?
Im Moment - soweit ich weiss -
ist es keines.
Aber das war ein grosses Thema.
- Ja.
Da gab es grosse Beziehungsprobleme.
Weil man ...
- ... untereinander ein bisschen ...
... ausprobierte ...
- ... ein Durcheinander machte.
Ja, man probierte aus.
- Wie geht man damit um?
Zusammen zu leben,
den Besitz und die Vision zu teilen,
ist das eine,
aber wenn es um Liebe geht ...
... wird es etwas schwieriger.
Dann geht das sehr nahe.
Das ist kein einfaches Thema.
Trotzdem ist es ein Thema.
Ich möchte auch dort
hinschauen können.
Das ist interessant.
Man sagt, verheiratet zu sein,
sei eine Art von Besitz.
M e i n  Mann.
- M e i n  Mann. Er gehört mir.
Ja, er gehört mir und nur mir.
Siehst du das auch so?- Nein.
Ich sehe das nicht mehr so.
Ich denke,
das hat sich bei mir geöffnet.
Hans hat Yamagishi
in die Schweiz gebracht.
Der Bauernsohn war in den 70er-Jahren
für ein Friedensprojekt in Japan
und lernte dort
ein Yamagishi-Dorf kennen.
Letzte Kuh das Gatter zu.
Was war dein Ziel?
Wolltest du Leute missionieren?
Nein,
ihnen die Gelegenheit geben ...
... sich selber kennenzulernen.
Findest du,
die meisten kennen sich zu wenig?
Sonst würde die Welt
nicht so aussehen.
Ein Mensch,
der sich kennt und frei ist,
führt keinen Krieg.
- Denkst du?
Nein. Wieso auch?
Das findet alles statt ...
Krieg führen und jemanden töten
kannst du nur,
wenn du denkst,
dass du von allem abgetrennt bist.
Wenn man die Realität sehen könnte,
nämlich, dass wir alle eins sind ...
Yamagishi
heisst ja "in einem Körper leben".
Das Universum und alles ist eins.
Wir denken zwar,
zwischen uns sei es leer,
aber da ist Luft
und jeder von uns hat eine Aura.
Das mischt sich ja alles.
Das sehen wir nicht.
Darum denken wir,
wir seien getrennt voneinander.
Wenn du realisierst,
dass wir alle eins sind:
Warum würdest du jemanden schlagen?
Weil er Geld hat und du nicht.
Du nimmst es ihm weg.
Das kannst du nicht,
wenn du siehst, dass alles eins ist.
Kann ich das dann nicht? Doch.
Kannst du schon,
aber du machst es nicht.
Ja ... Das ist der Punkt,
über den ich noch nicht hinwegkomme,
das merke ich.
Ich verstehe noch überhaupt nicht,
wie das funktioniert.
Das Ego ist das,
das sich separat sieht.- Ja.
Es hindert dich daran,
dich selber zu sehen.
Dein Ego teilt immer nur in gut
oder schlecht oder langweilig ein.
Up or down - Glück und Unglück.
Das Ego macht nur das.
Ja.
- Es geht immer hin und her.
Du fällst nicht vom Glück ins Unglück
und zurück.
Was ist dein Grundzustand?
- Zufriedenheit.
Zufriedenheit? Wirklich?
- Ja.
Wenn ich nicht zufrieden bin,
spukt das Ego garantiert wieder.
Wenn ich rausfinde,
was es ist, geht es weg.
Also, Zufriedenheit in dem Sinn,
dass du nicht findest,
du müsstest superglücklich
oder todunglücklich sein,
sondern eher so. Ist das das Ziel?
Ich weiss nicht, was ...
- Ausgeglichen.
Steckst du in dieser Dualität ...
- Du kannst nicht mit mir ...
... denkst du,
dass das hier langweilig ist.
Aber das ist es nicht ...
... sondern das Gegenteil.
- Ja.
Wahres Glück
ändert sich eigentlich nicht.
Wenn es sich ändert,
dann stimmt etwas nicht.
Aber hat man das wahre Glück
in sich drin?
Oder wo ist das?
- Du spürst es nicht wegen des Egos.
Das ist relativ einfach.
Ich finde trotzdem,
dass ich das ein bisschen spüre.
Aber ja ...
Bis man dir
dein Portemonnaie wegnimmt.
Ja, gut, also ...
Komm, gib mir noch ein paar Tage.
Mir brummt der Kopf.
Zeit für etwas Handfesteres.
Nik erzählt mir,
er sei letzte Woche
mit Frau und Kind vom Hof weggezogen.
Seine Partnerin
habe es hier nicht ausgehalten.
Ihr sei alles zu eng gewesen.
Er arbeitet aber weiterhin hier
und kann sich vorstellen,
später wieder hier zu leben.
Ist das eine Lebensform,
die du leben möchtest?- Mhm.
Ja.
- Ja.
Wieso?
Ja ...
Ich habe
viel Aktivismus ausprobiert:
die vegane Bewegung,
die Anti-Food-Waste-Bewegung,
Demonstrationen gegen Pestizide ...
... in besetzten Häusern leben ...
Das habe ich alles ausprobiert,
um irgendwie eine Gegen...
Als Gegenentwurf.
Um dieser Kraft
eine Gegenrichtung zu geben.
Und schlussendlich
merkte ich einfach,
dass es auf diese Art
nicht funktioniert.
Wenn ich auf dieser Welt
Frieden kultivieren will,
dann geht das nur in mir drin.
Das ist der einzige Ort,
an dem ich das kann.
Also suche ich ein Umfeld,
das das auch will.
Ist das ein Ort, an dem du
den Frieden in dir finden kannst?
Oder hast du ihn schon gefunden?
Nein,
gefunden habe ich ihn noch nicht.
Ich habe eher Krieg und Gewalt
in mir drin gefunden.
Sicher?
- Also, nicht hier,
aber ich habe realisiert,
dass das in mir drin ist.
Ich versuche,
das der Welt zuzuschreiben
und andere
dafür verantwortlich zu machen.
Aber es findet wirklich
in mir statt.
Die Gewalt und der Krieg
der Menschen ist in mir drin.
Das in mir aufzulösen, ist
die einzige Chance, die ich habe.
Sich selber betrachten.
Was kann ich
zum grossen Ganzen beitragen?
Nicht besitzen,
sondern teilen zu wollen.
Miteinander, anstatt jeder für sich.
Das sind Gedanken,
die voll dem Zeitgeist entsprechen.
Trotzdem kamen seit 20 Jahren
nur wenige neue Leute.
Warum habt ihr nicht mehr Zulauf?
Ich denke, die Menschen versuchen,
die Welt
für alle lebenswert zu machen,
indem sie
aktiv etwas gegen aussen machen -
z.B. recyceln
oder sich vegan ernähren.
Das hier ist wahrscheinlich
nicht so anziehend,
weil es
mehr nach innen gerichtet ist.
Es geht darum, dass ich selber ...
... die Welt nicht mit dem vergifte,
was ich ausstrahle.
Das ist ein bisschen anspruchsvoller
als PET zu recyceln.
Was hindert dich daran, so zu leben?
- So zu leben?
Wahrscheinlich mein Ego.
So nennt ihr das.
Ich sage, es sei mein Bedürfnis
nach Selbstbestimmung,
nach jener Art Freiheit,
die ich als Freiheit empfinde.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist es.
Und ich glaube, mir wäre das zu eng.
Ja.
Was für ein Gefühl habt ihr denn?
Sind Menschen unterschiedlich,
oder sind alle anderen
einfach noch nicht so weit wie ihr?
Jeder will glücklich sein
und versucht das auf seine Art.
Ja.
- Ja.
Und ich habe einfach herausgefunden,
dass man v.a. glücklich sein kann,
wenn man vieles loslassen kann -
Wertvorstellungen und Ideen,
an denen du bis jetzt
festgehalten hast.
Dass man immer wieder darauf schauen
und es spüren kann.
Ja.
"Jeder will glücklich sein
und versucht das auf seine Art."
Das nehme ich mit.
Und Respekt für diejenigen,
die den Mut haben,
es anders zu machen
als die grosse Mehrheit.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021